bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va tester
un nouveau produit dont on a parlé déjà
il ya quelques temps que j'ai pu prendre
en main directement lorsque j'étais au
cs à las vegas c'est le honor view
honorio 10 et le nouveau téléphone de au
nord donc dans cette vidéo ce qu'on va
faire ce qu'on va faire un test complet
de ce téléphone
on va faire un homme boxing on va
regarder comment il est présenté on va
regarder ce qu'il a dans le ventre
on va aussi tester les caméras avant et
arrière on va tester aussi
l'intelligence artificielle qui est
vraiment je dirais le nouveau cheval de
bataille de au nord au nord cherche
vraiment à rentrer dans la cour des
grands avec un produit à moins de 500
euros lors de la présentation au nord a
vraiment voulu comparer ce honorio 10 à
l'iphone 10 alors à mon avis on n'est
pas vraiment là dessus on est vraiment
sur un produit qui sera plus concurrents
du one + 5 t très clairement c'est un
produit qui s'inspire du huawei m'a dit
ce qui à un grand écran qui a une
nouveau processeur kirin 970 qui a
énormément de points positifs mais ça ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va déballer
on va regarder ça ensemble on va tester
en vraiment de choses et comme ça après
on verra si effectivement il est à la
hauteur de nos attentes
voilà la boîte de ceux au nord view
disent d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
remercier mon partenaire iphone planète
qui m'a permis d'avoir ce produit de le
tester en exclusivité alors ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va l'ouvrir on a
regardé effectivement ce que ces
honneurs vieux 10 a dans le ventre
comment il est fait un peu le packaging
site on va faire le tour un peu du
produit on va commencer par une chose
c'est effectivement l'ouvrir voilà la
bête on envieux 10 alors hop on va tout
de suite regardé comment il est fichu
souffre directement on n'aura qu'à
appuyer sur le bouton pour l'allumer
alors c'est vrai que d'un point de vue
prise en main d'un point de vue design
moi j'aime beaucoup ce dos en métal or
je sais qu'il a été beaucoup critiqué
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
aimait le dos en verre qu'on pouvait
retrouver sur le au nord 9 entre autres
et moi ce que je reprochais nommément à
ceux dont anvers est décédé très grosses
traces de douala avec ce modèle très
clairement il ya plus de traces de
doigts et je trouve que c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment super côté un peu
négatif moi c'est les choses que je
craindrais un petit peu utilisation cc
deux caméras qui sont quand même hyper
proéminente
elle dépasse donc lorsque vous posez
votre téléphone sur une table comme ça
vous risquez un petit peu de les rayer
et c'est vraiment le côté négatif que je
tiendrai là dessus donc c'est un produit
à mon avis sur lequel il faut absolument
une coque de protection si on veut pas
tout de suite l'endommager cam de prise
en main voyez j'ai pas une main de deux
gros moucheron ça ça tient quand même
plutôt pas mal
à l'avant vous avez votre caméra ici
votre bon parleur le bouton ici
clairement nous faisons pour
déverrouiller vous voyez sur le côté le
bouton de volume le bouton pour
l'allumer ici la prise jack
c'est un très grand fan de la prise jack
se faisait très très bien qu'il ait fait
le choix de l'heure de la conserver de
l'usb tic c'est ici
de l'autre côté votre slot pour brancher
votre carte sim et votre extension de
cartes mémoire mais bon vous avez déjà
128 giguère natif donc bon je suis pas
sûr que ce soit vraiment très
intéressant donc faux vrai que c'est un
produit qui est plutôt bien réussi qui
est ce la main dans la main une ce grand
écran est vraiment super 5,99 pouces fhd
plus de 1160 par 1080 format 18 ne
vienne je trouve que c'est vraiment bien
voilà résolution de 403 ppp c'est une
dali psc du lcd l'écran occupe plus de
85% de la face avant voilà pour moi
c'est vraiment un joli produit qui bien
réussi leur nez sur un android
8 oreo avec une surcouche em 8.0 dans
cette boîte là lorsque je louvre
qu'est-ce qu'on a alors on a le câble de
recharge en usb type c'est ici vos
oreilles être que vous pouvez brancher
toujours dans votre prise jack ça c'est
génial
oui c'est vraiment bien de garder le la
prise jack c'est un bon point il y en a
plein qui l'enlève notamment chez apple
bon moi je trouve ça un peu un peu
dommage vous avez ensuite ici
hop un guide de démarrage rapide une
carte de garantie et une coque de
protection que vous livrent directement
huawei avec pourquoi pour éviter
d'abîmer caméra à l'arrière alors bon
donc effectivement il faut les protéger
ses caméras là on est vraiment à fleurs
on est à fleur ce qui fait que les
caméras au sensation du toucher j'ai
l'impression qu'elle dépasse toujours
légèrement
c'est vrai que tout de suite avec cette
coque de protection c'est lukas un peu
son look on va pas dire ça il ya un côté
un petit peu un petit peu cheap os x
c'est ça c'est quand même le le côté un
peu dommage moi je préfère effectivement
de toute façon les smartphones l'égard
des nues ou alors faire comme sur le
mien me faire une coque personnalisé
monsieur heureux je trouve que voilà
c'est quand même plus sympa ça côté il
ya quand même un côté un peu un peu
cheap
dommage le déverrouillage par empreinte
digitale est extrêmement rapide vous
poser à peine votre doigt dessus claque
ça déverrouille directement c'est
vraiment vraiment hyper réactif
alors la surcouche em 8.0 on va en
parler pendant des heures mais c'est
vrai que alliés plutôt pas mal ce que je
remarque vraiment avec si toi tu es du
lycée je trouve qu'on est vraiment à mi
chemin entre de l'android et de laïos ça
me rappelle vraiment la navigation des
os même les icônes un peu bon
effectivement c'est pas exactement la
même chose
heureusement mais ça me fait vraiment
vraiment penser quelque chose qui fait
pas mal fichu c'est la reconnaissance du
visage pour déverrouiller son téléphone
comme ça hop
il reconnaît directement mon visage est
maintenant pour le déverrouiller g
kaffer et hop ça ne déverrouille hyper
rapidement si vraiment quelque chose de
très très réactif et ça c'est super
appréciable lorsque vous ouvrez une
application ça s'ouvre directement c'est
très très réactif
on va vraiment la puissance du
processeur kirin 970 couple est assis
giga de ram
on peut dire que ça fait vraiment
vraiment vraiment vraiment la faire ça
réagit tout de suite il ya pas de
latence j'ai fait pas mal de tests avant
déjà j'ai remarqué que ça les hyper vite
vous avez aussi nouveauté vous avez la
game suite ici lorsque vous aimez jouer
vous avez un mode intelligent cession
d'une interrompu c'est vraiment pas mal
lorsque vous voulez jouez pas être
embêté sa découpe un peu du reste du
monde
le verrouillage des touches de
navigation vous risquez pas d'appuyer
sur une touche à côté sortir du jeu
voilà c'est vraiment plutôt pas mal
foutu
lorsque vous jouez à des jeux je trouve
qu'effectivement c'est plutôt bien foutu
là on est sur assassin's creed sert
actes il n'y a pas de la galerie suis
pas sûr d hyper gourmand mais de ce que
j'en ai vu
que j'ai pu je suis morte de ce que j'ai
vu de ce que j'ai pu tester c'est vrai
que honor view 10 sur du jeu sur du game
vous avez très peu de latence parce que
vous avez vraiment de la puissance va
maintenant faire un test plutôt du côté
de la caméra pour voir un petit peu ce
que ça dit lorsqu'on veut faire des
photos vous avez à l'arrière un double
capteur 1 16 mégapixels pour la couleur
et un 20 mégapixels monochrome le 20
mégapixels va vraiment rajouter plutôt
du détail aux photos à pouvait faire
effectivement des photos noir et blanc à
noter aussi que la caméra avant 16
mégapixels d'une ouverture en point 8 ce
qui veut dire de la luminosité à l'avant
vous avez par contre une caméra
uniquement en 13 mégapixels alors du
côté du 13 mégapixels vous avez
effectivement pas mal aussi deux
possibilités vous avez le degré
d'embellissement c'est vrai que c'est
pas flagrant quand on regarde comme ça
de se rendre compte de ce cadre de ce
que ça va faire effet bloqué activée
alors ça c'est je trouve que c'est
vraiment pas terrible et effet bloqué
parce que ça reconnaît que mon visage
ça fait un flou avec des choses qui sont
très très mal définie si vous regardez
là son côté là je passe et ça se voit
bien ici là vous avez un flou au niveau
de mes cheveux c'est pas génial
il ya encore des choses à avoir de ce
côté là il faut savoir qu'en vidéo
pourrait filmer jusqu en 4k eut raté
c'est à dire du 3840 par 2160 pixels
donc vous pouvez naviguer dans vos mots
dit si vous avez les modes photo photo
photo pro alors photo pro vous pourrez
effectivement aller un peu plus loin
dans les réglages régler les iso
bouteille jusqu'à 3200 iso bavouzet
taille plutôt pas mal de réglages
alors bon il faut qu'ils connaissent un
peu pour aller gratter de ce côté là
sinon vous mettez le mode photo
automatique ça marche plutôt pas mal
le mode vidéo le mode vidéo pro dans
lequel vous allez effectivement aussi
pouvoir calibré votre auto focus en
manuels en continuant suivi vous allez
pouvoir régler pas mal pas mal de choses
aussi de ce côté là pour une fois de
plus il faut s'y connaître un petit peu
un objectif avec filtre infrarouge
panorama 3d monochrome côté monochrome
savait que durant du haut touquet à
l'écran ainsi plutôt pas mal foutu
vous avez les clichés hdr clichés
nocturne panoramique light painting time
lapse ralenti mode artistes filtre
filigrane scan de documents donc c'est
vrai que c'est très très très complet en
terme de photos et de vidéos
donc ce qu'on va faire maintenant c'est
qu'on va le tester directement
conditions durée
je vais arrêter de filmer que mon gh5 je
vais filmer uniquement avec le honor
view disent on va le tester en baissant
en éclairage et on va également
regardées du point de vue de la photo
faire différents clichés voir si ça
ramène du bruit oui ou non alors il faut
savoir qu'ici je suis dans une pièce où
il ya aucune lumière tout est fermé
aucune lumière de jour ne peut rentrer
j'ai uniquement deux éclairages
enfin trois éclairages avec ma petite
larme sur un côté c'est pas ça qui va
bien changer l'histoire
on va regarder ça et après on regardera
l'intelligence artificielle vis-à-vis
des photos du ono review 10 alors que là
j'ai mon gh5 qui filme et là je filme
avec le honor viau disent donc ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va comparer et puis
on va regarder si c'est bien ou pas donc
en train de filmer que le non-lieu 10
avec la caméra arrière
donc on va voir si effectivement les
vaches d'hérens là y'a aucune
colorimétrie pour qu'on puisse se rendre
compte quelque chose de très plat donc
l'image a effectivement changé par
rapport à ce que j'avais l'autre côté
mais l'idée c'est ça c'est vraiment de
se rendre compte de la qualité est ce
que c'est bien oui ou non et la
maintenance et sur les caméras avant de
ce hall nord view disent on va
effectivement qu'il ya une différence là
c'est une caméra 13 mégapixels fast est
sa caméra arrière en extérieur on va
regarder un petit peu filmés de trois
plans pour voir si c'est plutôt bien
fichu ou si c'est plutôt mal ce fut
lorsque je me mettrais très très fait
pas du tout le point dessus je pense
qu'à une distance minimale quand même
pour le focus
ouais là ça va pas trop mal par contre
c'est très brillant alors je sais pas
s'il rendu à la vidéo sera pareil ne
sont que ça sature énormément les
couleurs parce que ma fleur allait
vraiment jaune mais normal là c'est très
très très saturé
là c'est plus contrasté je trouve que
c'est plutôt pas mal fichu pareil
lorsque je me rapproche
je suis à 20 cm la mise au point se fait
pas et fait vraiment derrière ces
deux-là forcé mais il ya un bien génial
vraiment je reste à 50 cm 40 50 cm pour
avoir vraiment une mise au point au
dessus pour toi je teste la caméra de
cellfish en extérieur bon
c'est très c'est effectivement pas
complètement génial de ce que je vois
comme ça mais bon ouais c'est pas non
plus la caméra qu'on va utiliser le plus
agressif et très froid il doit faire ils
doivent faire quelque chose comme 5
degrés donc gelé prester énormément
dehors mais bon de toute façon cette
caméra de celle ci elle plus fait pour
effectivement déverrouiller faire
quelques souvenirs mais la meilleure
caméra sur cette aune ceux au nord gaudi
c'est vraiment situé à l'arrière
je trouve sur les caméras de celle fille
je vais tester la différence ou là je
suis en extérieur je vais rentrer dans
un intérieur qui est très sombre et voir
un petit peu la différence par comment
ça va se régler
vous allez voir donc la suisse obtient
rage extérieur et là d'un coup sam le
règle automatiquement toute la
luminosité et la lumière qui s'allume
saman tête ça me ramène un peu de grain
on le voit la voyez il ya du grain il ya
ça fait un effet un peu très bizarre il
ya en effet un peu lissé sur la peau un
grain que le logiciel c'est du lycée je
trouve que d'un point de vue qualitatif
c'est pas génial c'est un peu too much
ça fait un peu fait car bon vous voyez
j'ai pas une potiche alger paris j'ai eu
une peau parfaite mais bon donc on
continue à regarder un petit peu lâché
sur la caméra de selphy bon fouet c'est
pas génial sur du souvenir soit de
petites vidéos ça c'est quand même le
job on va tester mais pas la même chose
avec l'autre caméras mais kana la
principale
là je suis dehors on va rentrer
maintenant dans une zone qui est
beaucoup plus sombre parle affective
manger par auto moniteur donc je vois
pas c'est qu'il manque comment ça marche
je vois pas si c'est optimiser ou pas
mais voyant tout cas que la ici fait
libération
j'ai quelques éclairages dans une cage
d'escalier non brooks est pas hyper
optimisé mais en tout cas c'est rien ne
fait rien à faire donc maintenant on va
faire des thèses du côté de la
photographie au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle et la détection de scène
pour voir si ça marche pour voir comment
ça réagit et est-ce que c'est plutôt
bien optimisé ou pas alors j'ai fait
quelques photos en extérieur
je me suis rendu compte que la détection
de 16 marchés vraiment pour les plantes
le côté négatif c'est qu'effectivement
il ya une distance minimale pour que la
caméra arrière pissevin points lorsque
voulait faire un peu de maquereau de
toute façon il va falloir rajouter des
objectifs le problème c'est que rajouter
un gros objectif là dessus sur le double
capteur ça me semble compliqué avoir
peut-être car les accessoires qui vont
sortir qui le permettront en tout cas en
natif lorsque vous êtes trop près ça
marche pas il vous faut je pense quand
même c'est 50 cm pour sa piste
effectivement faire le point sur vos
photos par contre
du point de vue intelligence
artificielle sarr connaît très bien les
objets que vous allez prendre refaire le
test là par exemple je vous illustrez il
vous a ramené comment on va l'appeler
poète paul est la plante donc regarder
ce qu'on va faire c'est que on va
photographier paul est donc je prends
mon honneur view 10 je le mets devant
paulette c'est un mauvais exemple parce
que ça ne reconnaît pas du tout c'est
une plante lorsque je m'approche comme
ça à envoyer la savane le reconnaître la
scène m'affiche un petit peu l'icône ici
là au niveau de mon petit doigt
l'aca leur connaît et lorsque je suis
trop loin ça le reconnaît plus du tout
donc il faut vraiment que je me
rapproche alors ici oui hop là ça leur
connaît voilà ça reconnaît les fleurs je
fais une faute au tac mais je pense qui
si effectivement le problème que j'ai
c'est que j'ai un fond qui est un peu
complexe parce que d'un côté
j'aime hebbadj d'un autre côté derrière
je veux avoir toute la partie ici avec
mon club donc je complexifier un peu la
chose mais on va essayer maintenant sur
un fond qui est un peu plus notre pour
voir si elle reconnaît plus facilement
là j'ai plus grand chose en fond je le
prends en volume à distance sa marque
revenus directement le côté plante je
vais le mettre sur autre chose
up sur mon ordi à côté je re bascule sur
paul s et la salle et reconnaît
directement donc va maintenant se faire
un test de reconnaissance de scène avec
de la nourriture pour voir si ça marche
donc l'appareil
hop je pose directement devant et la
voyez il me reconnais directement que
c'est de la nourriture
donc maintenant on va le faire mais on
va complexifier un peu l'histoire on va
[ __ ] un peu le bordel on va rendre
une autre assiette alors assurez-vous
celle là celle de mon fils il le
reconnaît immédiatement puisque
l'intelligence artificielle marche et
reconnaît vraiment la forme de
l'assiette et reconnecte du coup c'est
la nourriture dedans on va complexifier
un peu les choses on va prendre le
carton à pizza mon carton avec ma pizza
au centre et la voyez typiquement il
reconnaît pas que c'est la nourriture on
va se rapprocher doucement pour voir si
ça change
lalala lalala toujours pas à ça y est il
vient de le reconnaître
donc voyez lorsque je suis trop loin je
pense qu'il va le reperdre lorsque je
suis trop loin ils voient quel tour du
carton ça le père et du coup
intelligence artificielle n'arrive plus
analysé la scène et à savoir réellement
de quoi on parle
mais dès que je me rapproche qu'il n'ya
plus que l'élément central c'est-à-dire
la nourriture
là il arrive à savoir de quoi on parle
donc fait des photos sans qui le
reconnaissent on va voir la différence
ici c'est vraiment optimisé ou pas voilà
ils ont fait des photos lorsqu il la
reconnaît et on verra effectivement s'il
ya une différence ça apporte vraiment
quelque chose
on essaye de faire des photos dans
différentes conditions de luminosité
donc là j'ai deux éclairages donc on va
essayer déjà faire une toute première
photo à leurs photos j'ai maintenant
couper la lumière d'un côté on a un
petit peu moins de lumière je vais
continuer hop je fais également une
photo donc là on est vraiment dans des
conditions sombre j'ai maintenant
tourner la lumière de l'autre côté donc
on a vraiment pas beaucoup de lumière
ici et voyez déjà ne serait-ce contrôle
gh5 ce qu'on voit réellement et lui
c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus
flatteurs donc là on est vraiment en
conditions de faible luminosité
je fais la photo donc ce qui est plutôt
pas mal c'est qu'on voit que d'un point
de vue de lumière dans différentes
conditions de luminosité
on a quand même un rendu qui est quand
même pas mal du tout donc là on va faire
le test de la traduction vous avez ici
un texte qui est probablement du
mondarrain là j'ai mon texte qui est là
je pose mon nom rioux 10 devant avec la
détection de la langue
hop j'appuie je prends une photo
sa recherche et là ça m'affiche le texte
elles ou en bonjour je suis arrivé à
tokyo la dernière voyons mal tout le
texte
c'est super impressionnant sur la
traduction c'est vraiment l'instantané
donc on va vraiment l'intérêt de ça
c'est lorsque vous êtes en voyage
vous avez accès à des informations
directement notamment dans des endroits
où effectivement on parle pas du tout
dans l'un ou l'autre des langues sont
très difficiles à comprendre comme le
mandarin je suppose une fois de plus bas
cet outil est vraiment pour ça super
impressionnant
donc après il ya différents modes de
traduction qui existe aussi la
communication entre deux personnes est
effectivement le microphone à la hausse
c'est vraiment hyper impressionnant
après purement et simplement ça quand on
regarde cet écran il a tendance à tirer
vers le bleu alors là effectivement vous
cache rien parce que forcément le fond
et bleu mais là là quand on le regarde
là c'est vrai que c'est très froid
il ya effectivement un côté bleu alors
ça vous pouvez le modifier dans
affichage vous allez ensuite dans
température des couleurs et là vous
pouvez le module et émettre un petit peu
là la température vous souhaitez alors
verdict de sonneurs viol disent est ce
qu'au final c'est un bon smartphone est
ce que c'est pas un bon smartphone alors
dans l'absolu je vous le dis moi je suis
convaincu je suis convaincu parce que
déjà on est sur un smartphone à moins de
500 euros et sa déjà rien que pour ça
pour l'effort c'est super on est
effectivement pas deux écrans oled
données sur un lcd une dalle épaisse
mais ça fait vraiment le job parce que
il est quand même bien contrasté
quand on regarde des photos quand on
regarde des vidéos quand on joue quand
on invite tout simplement sur son
téléphone
je trouve que la qualité est là le rendu
est là et on va vraiment qu'on a une
dalle de bonne qualité donc ça déjà
c'est un excellent point
ensuite d'un point de vue photo le
double capteur à l'arrière la 16
mégapixels couleurs et la 20 mégapixels
monochrome marche très bien ensemble on
voit qu'on adhérents d'une photo qui
fonctionne bien que ce soit dans des
conditions optimales de lumière comme en
faible luminosité
alors effectivement on n'est pas sur les
meilleurs appareils photos du monde on
n'est pas sur un mac 10 avec un
partenariat avec les cas mais
fondamentalement ça fait le job pour moi
le point négatif c'est la caméra avant
13 mégapixels
je trouve qu'il ya un traitement
logiciel qui n'est pas extraordinaire sa
tendance à lisser un petit peu ça fait
pas très très naturel les faits évoqués
pour moi aussi au niveau des contours
c'est pas hyper bien détaillé voilà
c'est pas ce qui se fait de mieux
mais une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone à moins de 500 euros dont il
faut pas non plus lui demander la lune
pareil en termes de fluidité de rapidité
la présence du processeur kirin 970
couple est assis giga de ram fait
vraiment la faire et en plus le stockage
128 giga à l'intérieur c'est vraiment
top
d'ailleurs on se dit qu'on pourrait même
se passer de l'emplacement avec la carte
mémoire à l'intérieur on n'aurait pas
forcément besoin sauf si vous êtes très
gourmand en terme d'audience de photos
et de vidéos
mais sinon dans l'absolu déjà 128 gia ça
c'est vraiment le job
en plus si un vrai confort de lecture
avec un écran 5.99 pouces avec ce ratio
18/9 c'est vraiment hyper agréable alors
on voit qu'effectivement on est dans la
tendance de fin de
17 2018 on va continuer avec des grands
écrans avec du bord à bord donc ça c'est
aussi vraiment très pratique et c'est en
saxe nord view 10 va vraiment se
démarquer par rapport aux autres
produits
la batterie fait la faire avec une très
bonne autonomie une 3750 millions
terreur c'est vrai que ce smartphone
il a quand même énormément de points
positifs à commencer par son prix
pareils la présence de la puce
elle put neuronale processing unit est
vraiment à comprendre est allé plus loin
dans l'intelligence artificielle et ça
on le bat notamment au travers des
photos pense que ça va reconnaître et
optimisez vos différents clichés on en
est qu'au début
l'intelligence artificielle n'est pas
très intelligente mais on voit que c'est
vraiment un paquet fait en avant on est
vraiment sur une tendance déjà présent
temps de l'es17 qui va aller plus loin
en 2018 et qui va continuer dans les
années à venir c'est à dire la
compréhension des machines de vos
utilisations de vos besoins de ce que
vous faites
alors au final est-ce que ceux au nord
view 10 vient concurrencer un iphone 10
pour moi non par contre il vient
concurrencer le one + 5 t très
clairement des smartphones de cette
qualité à moins de 500 euros une fois de
plus gros point positif
donc est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter si vous
avez un budget de moins de 500 euros et
que vous voulez un excellent téléphone
ce ono review 10 sera franchement la
faire je trouve séduisant par le design
je trouve hyper attrayant par la
fluidité parce que vous pouvez faire
avec la traduction génial les photos les
vidéos c'est bien la caméra de cette
fille c'est un peu moins bien mais bon
une fois de plus vous n'allez pas
dépenser 1000 euros donc gros pouce
bleus pour ceux au nord de baie but 2010
vite dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous l'avez acheté est
ce que vous l'avez essayé ce qui
pourrait vous tenter je pense que c'est
vraiment un smartphone qui risque de
vraiment bien fonctionné cette année
parce que il est hyper intéressant il a
beaucoup d'atouts
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire je vous invite bien
évidemment comme d'habitude à me laisser
des jolies pousse à vous abonner parce
que ça paraît toujours plus toujours
vous dire c'est que je vais continuer de
malades et à peu à droite à gauche pour
aller voir un peu l'année sentir un peu
les tendances voir les nouveaux produits
je serai au mwc à barcelone d'ici un
mois donc restez connectés je vous dis à
très bientôt portez vous bien n'oubliez
pas vous êtes les meilleurs
je vous embrasse sa hauteur
[Musique]